winter has come if the maesters are
right it'll be the coldest one in a
thousand years we should ride home and
wait out the coming storms the war is
not over and I promise your friend the
true enemy won't wait out the storm
it brings the storm what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another game
up or in season a discussion video today
I want to talk about the great war
against the night King I recently made a
video about how to defeat the undead
dragon Vissarion but now I want to talk
about the night king himself obviously
Westeros has a very big problem on their
hands now that the night king and his
army of whites white walkers in the
undead dragon have brought down the wall
during the game of Thrones season 7
finale
now that the others are invading
Westeros it's only a matter of time
before all hell breaks loose and the
north will be ground zero for the Great
War but will anyone be able to stop them
before their numbers grow even larger
we've all seen what is needed to kill
the White Walkers and whites but what
about the night King before I go any
further let me just make sure everyone
understands the differences between
whites and White Walkers because I know
some people still get them confused
first the White Walkers are the ones
that are in second command they
typically stay very close to the night
King almost like his own personal
Kingsguard but the night King also uses
his White Walkers to take care of some
of his more important missions like
obtaining Craster's sons the White
Walkers also have the power to reanimate
the dead which we learned during the
episode beyond the wall it's not exactly
clear how many White Walkers are left
but there don't appear to be very many
because we rarely ever see more than a
handful of them at a time but we don't
know how many groups of them are in his
army White Walkers are created from
living humans through some sort of
magical process and it's through this
process that makes them so powerful
because of the night King seems to be
transferring some of his own power into
them the White Walkers are just one
notch below the night king himself in
terms of what they are capable of Game
of Thrones has made it very clear that
White Walkers can be killed with either
Valyrian steel or dragon glass and we've
seen four of them killed so far one by
same wall Tarly in season 3 one by Jon
Snow in season five
by me reread in season six and another
by John during season seven White
Walkers however do not appear to be
susceptible to fire in the season 5
episode hardhome they are shown to snuff
out fire due to their extremely cold
bodies but that was just regular fire it
is unknown if they can be killed by
dragon's fire or wild fire secondly we
have the whites they are the zombie like
rain and made of corpses that populate
the vast majority of the night king's
army they're basically just humans that
were brought back from the dead but now
it takes a special weapon to kill them
for good the whites are the weakest of
the army of the Dead essentially zombies
they differ drastically from the white
walkers and appearance they often look
like decaying bodies while the white
walkers usually have long white hair and
pale blue grey skin the whites are the
foot soldiers of the army and the dead
and appear to take orders from their
white Walker superiors we know fire can
kill White's as we saw most recently
when Danny Unleashed her dragons and
when the TV show dragonglass also has a
special power to destroy White's now
this is not true in George RR Martin's
books but Game of Thrones writer Dave
Hill confirmed in a recent interview
that the show has deliberately changed
to this so even though the night King
has this massive army there are ways to
kill all of his soldiers and we learned
one very interesting piece of
information during last season the
episode beyond the wall taught us a
crucial detail about White Walkers and
their armies in jorah mormont was the
one to point it out when you kill a
white Walker it takes out all the whites
under their control and after learning
this beric Dondarrion realizes the only
way to win this war is to go after the
first white Walker ever created which is
the night king and according to him and
would destroy his entire army that seems
like a relatively simple concept kill
the night king haze dragon wolf all his
army will fall and the war is over
but if only it were that easy pi'm
he termed the moon you don't stop
berrak says to John all we have to do is
kill him
but John says you don't understand which
to me it implies it won't be so simple
after all if we assume the night king
can be killed just like any other white
Walker then he can be taken care of with
fire dragonglass Ian or Valyrian steel
however now that the night king has his
own dragon
it'll be incredibly difficult for anyone
to get close enough to him to do the
deed even if Daenerys uses her dragons
Viserion with his blue fire can
counteract that attack plus the night
King is smart and strong he was able to
kill this Ariane with one throw of his
spear one of the biggest problems is we
don't even know what weapons could kill
him even if John and the others were
able to get close enough it's difficult
to say what they could use to actually
take down the night king once and for
all
while it's known that White's are
susceptible to fire dragon glass and
Valyrian steel the night King himself
has never actually been attacked on
screen it's unclear whether he is
equally vulnerable to these weapons or
if he has some sort of immunity to them
but if John and his men can't take down
the night king in this way they can
still use their newfound knowledge to
chip away slowly at the rest of the
white Walker army they might be able to
destroy a big portion of the night
king's army if they take out all of the
other white walkers as soon as possible
since we know some of the whites were
turned by the white walkers to let me
ask all of you this how many of you
actually think what beric Dondarrion
said was true can the entire army of the
Dead be stopped if you kill the night
king the threat of the white walker
invasion has been lurking in the
background ever since the pilot episode
of the series so would they really allow
all of them to be defeated with this
simple concept the strength of the army
of the Dead comes from their massive
numbers and lack of fear they attack on
command and they even throw themselves
off cliffs further King they can be
defeated yeah
but now we know how vulnerable dragons
are when facing White Walkers
so bathing them all in fire at once is
no guarantee it's hard to imagine an
army of men being able to match the
firepower of a dragon so how do you
defeat such an enormous terrifying force
the knight king is incredibly powerful
and he's been around for a very long
time I've always been of the belief that
it will take a very special weapon to
defeat him since he is arguably the most
powerful character in the story I doubt
he can be killed with the same weapons
that kill the soldiers that are directly
under him White Walkers can be killed by
Valyrian steel and dragonglass
however the knight king is not like the
other light walkers he was the first and
the most powerful and he created the
other white walkers do you think the
knight King is immune to dragon glass
and Valyrian steel fire doesn't seem to
have any effect on him or the White
Walkers we have seen them walk right
through fire as if it weren't even there
the night King even walked through the
Dragon Fire array before he killed miss
Ariane so I think killing him a fire is
out of the question the next weapon
would be dragonglass since the night
King was created with dragonglass I
don't think it will kill him some
theories even suggest that if you take
the dragon glass out of his chest it
could stop him or turn him human again
it would almost be like taking the
battery out of something you would be
removing his source of power but this is
only a theory there is no actual proof
that this would work there are even some
theories that say the knight king will
never be defeated
that in the end they will either make a
new pact or the knight king will destroy
everyone and everything in his path
after all all men must die
death comes for them all it's the first
enemy and the last and they can never
defeat it kill Rory once said the knight
King will never die dragons can't get
near him he will always have a spear
handy and if a dragon even started to
fly at him he throw the spear and kill
it we know it can kill dragons because
we already lost one of them this way
even if a dragon could get near him what
good would it do
unlike other way walkers he's immune to
fire he walked right through the flames
and they dissipated as soon as he got
close
if drug on or a golf shot a blast of
flame at him it would never connect with
him he simply cannot be burned because
his aura prevents it
so only weapons of dragonglass or
Valyrian steel can kill him
and if Dragons can't get near him
without being fatally speared no human
can either besides even if they're
wielding one of those weapons they'd
have to cut their way through hundreds
of whites and some white walkers to get
to him and they'd likely be torn apart
if they tried third as if that wasn't
bad enough he's got an undead dragon on
his side now if he wasn't unstoppable
before he is now now I personally don't
see the knight king defeating everyone
because that would be too bitter of an
ending in my opinion like I said I think
it's gonna come down to a very special
weapon or at the least a very special
character brain Stark has to be
extremely important why wouldn't a
three-eyed Raven and the children
sacrifice themselves to protect him you
would think this has to be for the
greater good also his uncle Benjen told
him when the knight King comes you will
be waiting for him and you will be ready
it was good to control for a night King
comes
drink
one way another you will find his way to
the woman when he does you will be there
waiting for him and you will be ready to
me that sounds like by the time the
night king arrives brain will have some
sort of plan to defeat him or send him
back to the icy north there also has to
be a reason why so many characters have
brought up the prophecy of azor Ahai and
the prince or princess that was promised
it's a very old story that predicts the
coming of an ancient hero who will
defeat the great other the legend of
azor Ahai is scattered throughout the
books but in this series we've mostly
heard of this through Melisandre
Melisandre first believed that Stannis
was a Zora hi hen saw the horrific
sacrifices but when Stannis was defeated
on the battlefield
she turned her attentions to Jon Snow
some other people think it could be
Daenerys while others say it's Jaime or
even the Hound whatever the case may be
this person needs to reveal themselves
soon otherwise the night king may never
be stopped so what do all of you think
we'll then I king be stopped for good
and what's weapon do you think is needed
to take him down also do you believe
what beric Dondarrion said can the
entire army of the Dead be wiped out if
you cut the head off the snake
meaning the night king or will there be
some kind of a twist to his downfall let
me know what you think about this put
all your thoughts down below in the
comment section I enjoyed your feedback
on how to kill Vasari on so now I want
to hear what you have to say about how
to kill the night king thank you very
much for stopping by and watching
today's video I really appreciate that
and I also want to thank all of my
supporters on patreon have a great day
I'll see you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]